I read the book Breath by James Nestor  every single chapter in that book talks  about how mouth breathing is like the  coming of Satan all of these negative  effects is mouth breathing like actually  killing us you look at the experiment he  did where he bunged his nose up with two  earplugs for ten days he looked really  bad at the end of those 10 days within  the first day or so his blood pressure  had gone up x amount of points his sleep  was impacted and then I think he said  you know something like 30 the American  population are breathing like this all  the time when he took those earplugs out  of his nose within a matter of hours his  blood pressure started to come back down  again and started to feel more himself